Thea sagt jeweils
die neuen Chefs an.
Ja, das sind die neuen Chefs.
Und ein Chef
braucht auch einen Schlüssel.
Darf ich ihn dir übergeben, Sacha?
- Danke schön.
Geht vorsichtig damit um.
- Machen wir.
Vielen Dank. Wie ihr hört,
kommen wir aus der Schweiz.
* Leichte, beschwingte Musik *
Familie Almeida ist in ihrer
kanadischen Heimat angekommen.
Good morning.
- Hello.
Für die Kinder
hat die Schule bereits begonnen.
Und die Eltern
haben ihr Motel übernommen.
Wir sind Besitzer
eines grossen Motels - echt cool.
Susanne und Ruedi Althaus wollen
in Uruguay eine Ferienlodge bauen.
Für ihren Traum haben sie
ihr Heim im Emmental aufgegeben.
Ein neues Bett für ein neues Leben.
Ruedi ist bereits abgereist,
Susanne folgt in vier Monaten.
(Susanne) Tschüss zusammen!
Der Hund kommt mit,
die Kinder kommen nach.
Die Eltern Kunz
haben sich verabschiedet.
Ihre neue Existenz:
ein Imbisswagen an der Nordsee.
Nicht mehr Ferien, sondern arbeiten.
* Leichte, beschwingte Musik *
# Uf u dervo.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
In Kanada ist - zumindest
bei den Kindern der Almeidas -
der Alltag eingekehrt.
Tschau. Tschau, Robin.
- Tschau, Mama. - Rein mit euch!
Tschau, Sofie.
- Tschau, Sofie.
André, Sofie und Robin fahren - ganz
kanadisch - mit dem Bus zur Schule.
Alle gucken.
- Ja, alle gucken.
Very exciting
Toll. Gut, super.
Das klappt ja hervorragend.
Ein aussergewöhnlicher Tag hingegen
ist heute für die Eltern angebrochen.
Vier Monate war das Balmoral Motel
an der Main Street in Tatamagouche
geschlossen, jetzt eröffnen sie.
Jetzt der goldene Schlüssel rechts.
Das Leben als Hoteliers in Kanada
kann beginnen.
18 Zimmer und ein grosszügiger
Aufenthaltsraum warten auf Gäste.
Es wäre geöffnet.
Das Kartenterminal
ist gestern Abend auch angekommen.
Wir wären eigentlich bereit,
haben aber noch keine Buchungen.
Für heute nicht.
- Aber für Montag.
Wenn man hier rüberscrollt,
sieht man aber schon:
Hier sind erste Buchungen.
Für den Sommer usw.
Das sind immer noch Mai, Juni ...
Ein paar Buchungen sind schon drin.
Echt cool.
Mir ist es gerade recht so.
Es ist noch etwas chaotisch,
ich muss mich im Büro
erst noch zurechtfinden.
* Ruhige Musik *
Die Tourismussaison in Nova Scotia
beginnt im Mai.
Josef hat nur noch Zeit
für die nötigsten Reparaturarbeiten.
Noch lange ist nicht alles so,
wie er es gerne hätte.
Solche Dinge stören mich.
Das sieht man doch 100-mal am Tag.
Das muss sofort geflickt
und repariert werden.
Solche Dinge mag ich nicht.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
was das hier zu suchen hat.
Ja, ja.
Man kommt
mit der Vorstellung hierher,
dass es wie zu Hause sein soll.
Aber vielleicht
ist das auch mein Problem.
Ich muss mich wohl damit abfinden,
dass hier nicht alles so perfekt
wie in der Schweiz ist.
Viele Lichter funktionieren nicht.
Aber das sei okay
und nicht notwendig, sagen sie hier.
Ein Vorteil
gegenüber der Schweiz ist:
Almeidas haben hier eine Angestellte.
Ich bin mega froh.
I'm very happy to have you.
Es ist ein Glücksfall,
dass wir sie haben.
Sie weiss schon, wie es läuft,
und ich muss nicht selber putzen.
Yes.
Während für die Zimmer gesorgt ist,
macht das Buchungssystem Ärger.
Heute ist es mühsam.
Wir kommen nicht vom Fleck.
Eine Weile lief es nicht,
dann lief es wieder.
Vor ein paar Wochen
lief es noch, nicht?
Das hier.
Das ist ... Da haben sie ...
Nein, das ...
Echt mühsam.
Es funktioniert nicht.
* Entspannte Musik *
Auf der südlichen Halbkugel Amerikas,
in Uruguay,
beginnt Ende April der Herbst.
Am frühen Morgen
landen Ruedi und sein Kollege Markus
in der Hauptstadt Montevideo.
Hallo.
- Willkommen.
Ein Empfangskomitee, hallo!
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Danke vielmals.
Der Schweizer
hat eine Beraterin engagiert.
Die Deutsche Alex
hat ein grosses Netzwerk.
Wie fühlt es sich an?
Gut.
Es ist ein Umzug,
aber deine Frau fehlt noch.
Also ist es ein halber Umzug.
- Halber Umzug, 50 %.
Ein Vorbereitungsumzug.
Wie waren
die letzten 24 Std. in der Schweiz?
Ein Abschied ist immer schwierig.
Ein Abschied ist immer
etwas Definitives, ein Stück weit.
Das mag ich nicht,
das ist nicht mein Ding.
Der 53-Jährige
lässt die Metropole weit hinter sich.
Er wandert ins ländliche Uruguay,
in die Pampa, aus.
Nach gut 2 1/2 Std. Fahrt erreichen
sie das neue Zuhause des Emmentalers:
die Kleinstadt
Colonia del Sacramento.
Für die ersten Wochen hat Ruedi
an der Avenida General Flores
ein Zimmer bei Señora Ines gemietet.
(Alex) Hola, Ines.
Hola.
- Hola.
... cocinarte algo.
Wenn du eine Herdplatte brauchst,
kann sie dir ...
Muss ich eh noch kaufen.
- Oder du kaufst hier was ...
Ich brauche sie
sowieso gleich wieder.
Okay.
- Muy bien.
Gut.
Der Handel ist perfekt.
Hallo, Schatz.
Geht's dir gut?
Du, tipptopp, alles sehr gut.
Ich bin in meiner neuen Wohnung.
Danach geht's auf unser Land.
Pass auf dich auf.
Merci, ich dich auch.
Tschüss. Tschau, tschau.
Ja.
Ja ...
Einerseits bin ich es mir gewohnt.
Aber es sind doch
dreieinhalb, fast vier Monate,
die ich jetzt allein bin.
Ich hoffe, es geht vorwärts,
dann komme ich auf andere Gedanken.
Aber wenn man dann
seine Frau so hört,
kommt es einem doch komisch vor.
Da Susanne bei den ersten Arbeiten
nur wenig helfen könnte,
ist sie in der Schweiz geblieben,
um weiterhin Geld
für ihr Projekt zu verdienen.
* Leichte, beschwingte Musik *
* Gemütliche Musik *
An der Nordseeküste in Deutschland
sind Brigitte und Sacha Kunz
gemeinsam unterwegs.
Ihre Geschäftsgrundlage,
der Imbisswagen, steht bereit.
Nun geht es um die Details.
Moin.
- Moin.
Ah, mit Kamera. Kaspari.
- Hallo. - Freut mich.
(Brigitte) Es ist alles
auf dem Stick, hoffentlich.
Der Imbisswagen
bekommt einen neuen Namen
und ein eigens entworfenes Logo.
Nimmst du es echt?
Wo kommt das jetzt hin?
- Oben.
Hier oben, einmal?
- Oben genau.
Oben die Beschriftung, genau.
Die Klappen werden ja geöffnet.
Und hinten.
Das ist der hintere Teil.
Wir sassen als Familie zusammen.
Jeder liess seine Fantasie spielen
und nannte ein paar Namen.
Eine Idee war der Küsten-Imbiss
mit der Robbe und der Wurst.
Jeder hat seinen Senf
dazu beigetragen.
So ist das eigentlich entstanden.
Wir haben das quasi
in der Familie so beschlossen
und brachten es so auf Papier.
Noch T-Shirts, ja.
Auch die Arbeitshemden
sollen Wurst und Robbe schmücken.
Polohemden.
- Okay, Polohemden.
Da würde ich ...
- Etwa neun, oder?
Nein,
man muss sich täglich umziehen.
Ich habe zu Hause
eine Waschmaschine.
Pro Person drei bis vier
würde ich schon nehmen.
Ich hätte gesagt: "Pro Person drei."
- Vier sicher. Vier auf jeden Fall.
Das sind ...
- Vier mal drei, das gibt zwölf.
Ja, ist super.
Vielen Dank. Danke schön.
Tschüss. Danke schön.
- Danke. Bis bald.
Danke schön. Vielen Dank.
Und auf geht's:
Die künftigen Grillmeister haben noch
einiges auf ihrer Pendenzenliste.
* Fröhliche, beschwingte Musik *
In Tatamagouche
ist es Abend geworden.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Nur das Problem
mit dem Buchungssystem
haben die Almeidas
noch immer nicht lösen können.
Hi.
Beatrice sucht Rat bei Jim,
dem früheren Besitzer des Motels.
Er hat irgendetwas vermurkst.
Die E-Mail-Adresse ...
Er kann seine E-Mails
nicht mehr abrufen.
Es gibt keinen Support mehr,
er erreicht niemanden,
das Passwort funktioniert nicht.
Die E-Mails an diese Adresse
sind irgendwo ...
Jetzt heisst es: "No internet."
Was ist da nur los?
* Türglocke *
Vorbesitzer Jim
ist ein hilfsbereiter Mensch.
Er will das Problem sofort lösen.
Hello.
Then Bea can check
all these e-mails.
Dass sämtliche Buchungsanfragen
noch immer über Jims Handy laufen,
muss sich schleunigst ändern.
Jim verspricht,
das Problem zu beheben.
So geht es nicht.
So?
Sleep well, thank you. Bye-bye.
- See you in the morning.
Hast du dich verabschiedet?
- Bye.
Bye-bye.
- Bye-bye. - Bye.
Doch kaum haben die Vorbesitzer
das Motel verlassen,
haben die Almeidas
ein neues Problem: der Drucker.
Es funktioniert noch immer nicht.
Scan ...
Egal, was wir probieren,
es funktioniert nicht. - So gemein.
Es funktioniert einfach nicht.
Punkt.
* Leichte, beschwingte Musik *
Trotz langer Reise:
Noch am Tag der Ankunft
will Ruedi seinem Kollegen Markus
das Grundstück zeigen.
(Markus) Du hast recht, das ist
eine sehr abenteuerliche Zufahrt.
Das Grundstück liegt 10 Autominuten
von Colonia del Sacramento entfernt.
(Ruedi) Schauen wir mal,
ob der Schlüssel passt.
Ist gut?
Ich habe ein Stück Land,
ein Grundstück,
und habe keinen Zutritt.
Der Gärtner
hätte es austauschen sollen.
Er hatte nur noch einen Schlüssel
für dieses Schloss.
Da er dies noch nicht getan hat,
müssen wir jetzt klettern.
5 ha gross ist das Landstück.
(Markus)
Das hat etwas von einer Juraweide.
Das ist ein schönes Stück Land.
Knapp 2 Fr.
kostete der Quadratmeter Bauland.
Hier unten soll es einen Pool geben.
Aber das ist noch Zukunftsmusik.
Wir möchten einen Teich anlegen,
einen Naturteich.
Das ist gewaltig.
Eine Riesenfläche.
- Das ist schön.
Es wäre schön mit den Bäumen,
wenn sie denn bleiben dürfen.
Die bleiben.
Das Gefühl ist gut.
Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl.
Wenn man sich umschaut:
Hier hat man seine Ruhe.
In dieser Idylle wollen Ruedi
und Susanne eine Posada bauen,
eine Ferienlodge mit fünf Häuschen,
einem Restaurant und Pool.
Doch die ersten Probleme
mit dem Baumeister sind schon da.
Erst kam keine Offerte, dann konnte
ich die Mengen nicht nachvollziehen.
Morgen sehen wir dann,
wie es weitergeht.
Finden wir eine
für beide Seiten akzeptable Lösung,
können wir mit dem Bau beginnen,
sonst schauen wir weiter.
Im schlimmsten Fall
fahre ich den Bagger.
Bzw. Markus übernimmt diese Arbeit
drei Wochen lang.
Anders geht es nicht.
Probieren wir's.
- Das wird schon klappen.
Dort oben ist der letzte Strommast.
Wir ziehen das Kabel
nach hier vorne.
Dort sollte irgendwo ...
* Entspannte südamerikanische Musik *
Noch in gewohnter Umgebung
arbeitet Susanne Althaus.
Salut.
Sie ist Pflegefachfrau
auf der Onkologieabteilung
des Berner Inselspitals.
Die 52-Jährige ist die Älteste
und Erfahrenste im Team.
Die Patienten
brauchen ihre volle Aufmerksamkeit.
Grüezi. Hallo.
- Hallo.
Wir haben damit begonnen,
das Perfalgan zu reduzieren.
Dann starten wir wieder
mit Antibiotika.
Kommt Ihr Mann am Abend zu Besuch?
- Heute nicht, nein.
Ist gut? - Super.
- Also ...
Bis nachher. Auf Wiedersehen.
- Danke vielmals.
Ich denke nur selten an Uruguay.
Hier muss meine Konzentration
ganz der Arbeit gelten.
Ausser vielleicht
in einer ruhigen Minute.
Dann erzähle ich den Kolleginnen,
was in Uruguay läuft.
Du willst einen Ovokeks,
das weiss ich.
Ja, ich weiss.
Für die jungen Pflegefachfrauen ist
Susanne mehr als nur eine Kollegin.
Ich werde meine Kinder hier
auf jeden Fall vermissen.
Sie ist unsere Mutter.
- Ja, die Mutter.
Das Team ist mir ans Herz gewachsen
in diesen fünf Jahren.
An der Nordsee arbeitet das
Ehepaar Kunz seine To-do-Liste ab:
Der erste Besuch
bei einem Wurstlieferanten
stimmt Sacha zuversichtlich.
Er machte auf mich
einen guten Eindruck.
Die Preise sind eigentlich auch ...
... so,
wie ich sie mir vorgestellt habe.
Wir werden vielleicht
noch eine, zwei Firmen anfragen.
Der Weg ist noch etwas weit.
Auch das werden wir
in den Griff kriegen.
Stell dir vor: Wenn du jeden zweiten
oder dritten Tag einkaufen musst -
und das wird so sein -,
dann fährst du alle zwei
oder drei Tage nach Cuxhaven.
Wir wissen,
wie gut es im Sommer läuft.
Dann werden wir viel Ware brauchen.
Entweder schaffen wir uns
ein ganzes Kühlhaus an ...
Irgendwie.
... oder wir fahren
alle zwei, drei Tage.
Dazu könnte uns
mit der Zeit die Lust fehlen.
Es sind doch 20 Min.
Für einen Weg.
Aber wir schauen mal.
* Gemütliche, sehnsüchtige Musik *
Würste allein
machen noch keinen Grillimbiss.
Wichtigste Beilage
sind Pommes frites.
Auch an diese
hat das Ehepaar hohe Ansprüche.
METRO GASTRO, schönen guten Tag.
Hier ist Kunz. Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Ich wollte Sie gerne fragen,
ob Sie auch frische Pommes führen.
TK.
Entschuldigung?
- Tiefkühl.
Nur tiefgekühlt?
- Ja.
Okay.
Damit haben Sie mir schon geholfen.
- Danke schön.
Bitte schön.
- Schönen Abend. Tschüss.
Ebenso. Tschüss.
(Susanne) Nein.
- In dem Fall nichts.
In dem Fall nichts.
Wir hätten gerne frische Pommes -
nicht tiefgekühlte, sondern frische.
Weil sie geschmacklich
einfach besser sind.
Aber es ist gar nicht so einfach,
einen Lieferanten zu finden.
Kevin, ihr ältester Sohn,
will zu seinen Eltern
nach Deutschland ziehen.
Der gelernte Elektriker hilft
schon mal bei der Strominstallation.
Kann ich einschalten?
Achtung!
Oh.
Die ist schön, nicht?
Auch Kevin soll in Zukunft mit seinen
Eltern hinter dem Grill stehen.
* Fröhliche, treibende Musik *
Im oberen Stock des Wohnhauses
richtet sich der 19-Jährige
eine eigene kleine Wohnung ein.
(Sacha)
Nicht so hoch.
Bist du sonst fertig?
- Ja.
Okay, dann mache ich zu.
Kevin ist sehr wichtig.
V.a. Ende Juli, Anfang August,
wenn wir zu arbeiten beginnen.
Dann sind ja Herbst... Sommerferien.
Von daher ...
Er ist unsere dritte Person.
Im Wagen muss man zu dritt sein,
sonst reicht es nicht.
* Fröhliche, beschwingte Musik *
Kaum funktioniert das Buchungssystem,
stehen schon erste Gäste
vor dem Motel.
Are you our guests?
- Yes.
Kannst du schnell aufhalten?
- Ja, mache ich.
Es ist bereits über Booking bezahlt,
nicht? - Ja.
Du hast ihnen Zimmer 9 zugewiesen.
Also musst du
Schlüssel Nummer 9 fassen.
Dann schauen wir kurz,
ob das Zimmer bereit ist.
Ich muss nur noch ...
- Soll ich gehen?
Ja, geh doch kurz
das Zimmer anschauen.
Ganz unauffällig.
Um sicher zu sein,
dass alle Tücher bereit sind.
Ich muss kurz schauen,
ob alles in Ordnung ist.
Das sieht gut aus, wunderbar.
Schliessen wir die Tür wieder.
Wunderbar.
Die Reservierung hat geklappt.
Das Paar muss nur noch
die Bestätigung unterschreiben.
Doch Josef
kann sie im System nicht finden.
Check-in, das haben wir gemacht.
- Speichern.
Check-in-Form ...
- Ich rufe kurz an.
Now, my question is:
It's all the same amount.
That's all.
Thank you very much for your help.
Yes. Thank you so much.
Have a good evening. Sleep well.
Bye-bye, thanks.
Weisst du,
was wir auch noch tun müssten?
* Beatrice lacht. *
Unser erster Gast.
- So cool!
Für den zweiten sind wir gewappnet.
Aber das Formular
muss ich nochmals ausdrucken.
Oder ich versuche gleich,
das zu ändern.
Nicht mehr Schüpbach an der Emme.
Am Rio de la Plata
in Colonia del Sacramento,
der ältesten Stadt Uruguays,
ist Ruedis neues Zuhause.
* Ein Hund bellt. *
550 $ kostet das Zimmer
monatlich bei Señora Ines.
Gracias.
- Ponla alla.
Es ist schon etwas speziell,
dass man nur noch ausgibt
und nichts mehr reinkommt.
Wobei das in unserem Budget
so vorgesehen ist.
Dazu kommen auch noch Reserven.
Wir können zwei Jahre hier leben,
ohne etwas zu verdienen.
Aber Druck ist auch vorhanden.
Heute trifft Ruedi
seinen künftigen Baumeister Mauricio.
Da vorne rechts ist der Eingang.
Alex, die Beraterin,
hatte das Grundstück vermittelt.
Heute ist sie
nur zum Dolmetschen mit dabei.
Zur Besprechung
ist auch Architektin Jimena gekommen.
* Begrüssung auf Spanisch *
Hola.
- Cómo estás? - Bien.
Noch einmal
wollen sie die Baupläne durchgehen,
Änderungen vornehmen und Missver-
ständnisse aus der Welt schaffen.
Es la plaza de cámara?
Als gelernter Bauschreiner
mit jahrelanger Erfahrung
hat Ruedi klare Vorstellungen.
Dass ich Bauleiter im Kosovo war,
mit Brücken-,
Strassen- und Häuserbau,
bringt sicher etwas.
Dazu kamen Ausstellungen.
Ich hatte einen tieferen Einblick
in Sachen, Details,
wie es gemacht wird -
das kommt mir jetzt sicher zugute.
Wobei wir
nicht mehr in der Schweiz sind.
Man darf den südamerikanischen Touch
nicht vergessen.
Sie machen viele Dinge anders -
aber sicher auch gut.
Es ist manchmal eine Gratwanderung.
Si la hace por aca ...
Auch Mauricio
ist ein erfahrener Berufsmann.
Bald steht einem akzeptablen Kosten-
voranschlag nichts mehr im Wege.
Bist du damit einverstanden?
Oder willst du Kostenvoranschläge
anderer Firmen?
Nein. Ich möchte mit ihm bauen.
Bueno, Mauricio, nos hablamos.
Chao!
Gracias.
* Leichte, beschwingte Musik *
Wasser beruhigt.
Auch am Wasser liegt der künftige
Arbeitsplatz von Familie Kunz.
Auf der Dorumer Platte 1
stehen mehrere Imbisswagen.
Hier gibt es Rollmöpse, Matjes,
Krabbenbrötchen und Crêpes zu kaufen.
Würste und Frikadellen
werden das exklusive Angebot
von Brigitte und Sacha sein.
Der Wagen, der von nun an die
fünfköpfige Familie ernähren soll,
ist nicht irgendein Grillwagen.
Sein ehemaliger Besitzer Pommes-Peter
ist eine lokale Grösse.
Hallo, Peter.
- Sacha, schön, dass du da bist.
Mit einem Festakt will der Deutsche
den Schweizern den Wagen übergeben.
Nach 25 Jahren wollen Pommes-Peter
und seine Frau kürzertreten
und haben einen ihrer Wagen
nun verkauft.
Ich würde gerne
ein paar Worte sagen.
Dann übergebe ich
euch den Schlüssel.
Ich bitte dich nach vorne,
übergebe dir den Schlüssel,
wünsche euch alles Gute
für die Zukunft,
und dann wäre es schön,
wenn du auch noch ein paar
nette Worte von dir geben könntest.
Hast du mitbekommen,
wie es abläuft? - Nein.
Du musst eine Ansprache halten.
- Nein, sicher nicht!
Sicher nicht!
* Volkstümliches Lied
auf Plattdeutsch *
Alles gut?
- Ja.
Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass so viele Menschen
unseren Abschied miterleben möchten.
Dafür möchten wir uns bei euch
recht herzlich bedanken.
Wir möchten unseren Betrieb abgeben
an die Familie Kunz aus der Schweiz.
Darf ich euch nach vorne bitten?
Thea sagt jeweils
die neuen Chefs an.
Ja, das sind die neuen Chefs.
Und ein Chef
braucht auch einen Schlüssel.
Darf ich ihn dir übergeben, Sacha?
- Danke schön.
Geht vorsichtig damit um.
- Machen wir.
Vielen Dank. Wie ihr hört,
kommen wir aus der Schweiz.
Wir wünschen der Familie
natürlich auch weiterhin alles Gute.
Wir werden ja weitermachen.
Am nächsten Freitag
ist die Eröffnung.
Um 12 Uhr geht es dann los für uns,
bis Ende Oktober.
Und dann schauen wir wieder weiter.
Ich bedanke mich
schon jetzt im Voraus
und wünsche Ihnen
noch einen schönen Tag.
Danke.
Marianne, bitte schön.
Sind die für mich?
- Ja.
# My Bonnie is over the ocean.
Wir sehen uns.
Alles Gute für den Neustart. Wir
haben uns ja schon kennengelernt.
Danke schön.
# My Bonnie is over the ocean.
Wir haben gut davon gelebt,
natürlich.
Wir konnten uns jedes Jahr
einen schönen Urlaub gönnen.
Dafür haben wir aber auch
sieben Tage die Woche gearbeitet.
Ich zähle
auf unser Durchhaltevermögen.
Das brauchen wir auch
für die nächsten 25 Jahre.
Ich hoffe,
dass wir hier glücklich werden.
Also ...
Alles Gute.
Viel Erfolg.
- Danke. Danke.
Und immer schönes Wetter.
- Immer schönes Wetter, ja.
# Bring back, bring back ...
Jetzt fehlen nur noch die Kinder.
Aber die kommen ja
in zwei Wochen nach.
Und wir ... Hallo. Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen.
- Danke.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl.
Den Schlüssel haben wir.
* Leises Vogelzwitschern *
Einmal mehr muss Beatrice den
Vorbesitzer des Motels um Rat fragen.
Der Gasherd springt nicht an.
Was machst du, Mami?
- Geh bitte beiseite.
Er müsste von selbst starten.
- Nein.
Die Almeidas haben das Motel
samt Inventar gekauft.
Vom Gasanzünder
über den Herd, die Betten
bis hin zu den Putzlappen
und auch den Servierschürzen -
alles war im Kaufpreis inbegriffen.
Man entdeckt
immer wieder neue Dinge.
Die schwarze Schürze
passt vielleicht besser zu mir.
It smells from the gas.
* Klicken *
Der funktioniert eben nicht richtig.
Welcher ist es jetzt?
Verstehst du das Problem?
Ah, here, now.
Jesses Gott! One moment.
Das war schon länger
nicht mehr in Betrieb.
Man muss einiges ersetzen.
So.
Zwei Scheiben Toast.
Vorne gibt's noch mehr.
Ja, nicht mehr.
Wie sieht es aus?
Was ist hier noch?
Thank you.
- Enjoy it.
That's so good.
* Ruhige, idyllische Musik *
Kaum sind die ersten Gäste versorgt,
kommen schon weitere an.
(Josef) Hello.
Great.
Bea? Ich brauche deine Hilfe.
Ich habe Probleme mit dem System.
Wie komme ich wieder raus?
Der ist erfasst ...
Und doch: Es scheint, dass es
mit jedem neuen Gast besser geht.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Im Industriegebiet von Montevideo
will sich Ruedi
einen Radlader kaufen.
Mit dem entsprechenden Zubehör kann
er diesen als Mäher, Gabelstapler
und nicht zuletzt
als Bagger einsetzen.
Permiso.
Alex' heutiger Auftrag
ist einmal mehr das Übersetzen.
Hola.
- Hola.
Hola, Victor.
- Hola. Qué tal? Bienvenidos.
Gracias. Okay ...
Ein wichtiger Zusatz ist die Bagger-
schaufel mit entsprechendem Arm.
Doch genau diese Teile
hat der Verkäufer nicht an Lager.
Zwei Monate, die sind nicht da.
- Die 120er?
Pero para traerlos
hay un costo muy alto.
Claro, el transporte.
Oder für mehr als 1'000 $
mit dem Flugzeug herbringen.
Ein kompletter Scheiss.
Aber mal schauen,
was für Möglichkeiten er hat.
Irgendeine Lösung
findet sich schon.
Der Verkäufer will den Deal
schnellstmöglich abschliessen
und sucht auf dem ganzen Kontinent
nach Schaufel und Arm.
* Bedächtige, hüpfende Musik *
Um Ruedi bei Laune zu halten,
darf er eine erste Runde
mit dem Radlader fahren.
Schon bald
hat der Verkäufer Neuigkeiten.
In Paraguay ist es da.
Also ... Den Arm haben sie,
aber nicht die Schaufel.
Jetzt müssen sie
nach einer Schaufel suchen.
Eine Puzzlearbeit.
- La felicidad nunca es completa.
* Treibende Musik mit Tubaklängen *
Am Tag nach der Schlüsselübergabe
weht an der Nordsee
eine steife Brise.
Bevor den Imbisswagen
das neue Logo ziert,
muss die Fassade gereinigt werden.
Der Wagen selbst ist bereits sauber.
Ihr wart wirklich fleissig.
Ich habe ihn nochmals
schön sauber gemacht.
So gut ich konnte.
- Perfekt.
Die habe ich gestern Abend
noch gemacht.
Die ist ... gebraucht,
aber eigentlich noch frisch.
Das ist ganz neu.
- Die ist frisch.
Mein neues Reich.
- Dein neues Reich.
Ja.
Mehr als sauber.
Das hat Marianne ganz toll gemacht.
Es windet noch immer,
und es ist noch immer kalt.
Wir hoffen auf besseres Wetter
in den nächsten Tagen.
Es sieht nicht so schlecht aus.
Wenn es am Freitag
bei der Eröffnung nicht regnet,
haben wir schon viel erreicht.
Der Sommer hat uns dieses Jahr
noch nicht verwöhnt.
Das ist aber noch kein Sturm.
Sturm haben wir erst, wenn
die Schafe keine Locken mehr haben.
Das Wetter ist immer schön.
Da haben die Möwen
ganz schön was hinterlassen.
Es soll Glück bringen,
wenn dich eine Möwe trifft.
Dann solltest du Lotto spielen.
Ihr geht schrubben,
wir gehen Pizza essen.
Macht das. Schönen Abend.
Geniesst den Abend.
- Tschüss.
Macht's gut. Schönen Abend,
guten Appetit. Tschüss!
Hier hat wirklich
eine hingeschissen.
Aber ich glaube,
Wasser sollte reichen.
Der ist nicht fettig.
Ich dachte, der sei fettig?
- Nein, nicht fettig.
Sie gehen morgen
mit Alkohol dahinter.
* Gemütliche, sehnsüchtige Musik *
Ist das alles?
Komm, Falco!
- Falco, geh weg!
Benutze drüben den Spray.
Wir sind beide Chefs.
Aber ... na ja ...
... man muss vorwärtsmachen,
damit es gut kommt.
Wir arbeiten ja beide gleich viel.
Wir kennen uns so lange und so gut.
Deshalb bin ich fast sicher,
dass es keine Probleme geben wird.
Er erwähnte noch die Kanten, nicht?
Oh!
Schatz.
- Ja?
Wasser.
- Nein.
Mist!
Ich bin tropfnass.
(Ironisch) Und es ist superwarm.
Etwas, woran es in Uruguay
kaum mangelt, ist Fleisch.
Während der Baumaschinenverkäufer
in halb Südamerika
das fehlende Zubehör sucht,
essen Ruedi und Alex in einer
typischen Parrillada zu Mittag.
Auf das erste Mal El Palenque
in Uruguay als Einheimischer!
Danke. - Fast.
- Fast, ja.
Mit oder ohne Schaufel.
Wie so oft im Leben
läuft nicht alles wie gewünscht.
Das Leben ist kein Keks,
sonst würde jeder daran knabbern.
Mit vollem Bauch
geht es zurück zum Verkäufer.
Wenn es im April kommt,
dann ist gut.
Das restliche Zubehör kann er
wahrscheinlich schon eher liefern.
Den Rest der Maschine
kann er ja schon früher liefern.
Ach so, ja klar,
mit dem restlichen Zubehör.
Dann kannst du schon mal Rasen mähen
und dich damit anfreunden.
Gracias. Muchas gracias.
* Entspannte,
südamerikanische Musik *
Sag nicht, ich bin zu schwer!
Machst du Gewichtskontrolle?
Damit habe ich
jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Wie eine Kirmes.
In der nächsten Folge
kommt Susanne in Uruguay an:
Nein, ich bin nicht traurig.
Ich bin einfach überwältigt
von all dem.
Sie muss vorläufig
in einen Wohncontainer ziehen.
Cool. Aber kalt.
Das Ehepaar Kunz
hat die perfekte Wurst gefunden.
Das sind Currywürste,
je 180 g schwer.
Grosse Hektik am Eröffnungstag:
Schatz ...
Nein, ehrlich,
du kannst doch nicht ...
Das geht nicht nebenbei.
Wir müssen vorwärtsmachen.
Und du musst richtig putzen.
Langsam.
Trotz Hochsaison:
Im Balmoral Motel wollen die Almeidas
die Gästezimmer renovieren.
Und nehmen sich endlich Zeit
für einen Ausflug.
Es ist herrlich, herrlich.
Ganz ruhig.
# U si stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für es neus Dahei.
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2020